with over 300 million sold almost
everyone has played with a slinky but
almost no one has taken it as far as
this man turning a childhood toy into a
visually stunning art form
[Music]
this is Josh Jacobs AKA Slinky Josh one
of the world's best Slinky artists and
an important member of the burgeoning
slinky manipulation Community people
often ask me how long have you been slow
and then you can see their brain sort of
like hit a Crossroads and they're like
slinkying but I much prefer to shorten
it to slinking for past tense slinked no
slunk
one of my most technically challenging
tricks would be energy beam twists
rapidly rotating between two different
twists
with one hand on top and one on the
bottom like this
when I'm doing a Twist like this I can
let go of one side the slinky will
repeat that pattern in the air this one
I called a dragon and this is one of the
biggest crowd Pleasers
the distance that I'm standing away from
them matters a lot because it sort of
swings out like right in front of their
face a lot of people assume that I have
been practicing Slinky manipulation
since I was a kid but that is not at all
true Slinky manipulation is a very new
art form it only started around 2010
eight years ago I saw a video of a
Chinese guy doing all this crazy stuff
and I was like what is that is that real
I need to learn how to do that so I
started wearing it on my wrist
everywhere and just practicing all the
time and I started making YouTube
tutorials and then stuff kind of took
off from there Josh's performance is wow
and Delight audiences any fiends on that
energy as an artist performing at
festivals and street corners he's even
made a business selling slinkies I've
always loved doing unique types of
performance and also doing stuff that
gives people that wow shock Factor
that's wild dude if I was on a
desert island Island and I didn't have
anybody to share this art form with I
would have stopped long ago one day I
would love to see a world Slinky
competition like they have with yo-yos I
want to spread this to people all around
the globe who's coolers thank you
manipulators no comment
within Slinky manipulation there are a
couple fundamental moves that almost all
of the other tricks are built upon first
one of those is called the energy beam
I am tugging on one side which creates
this wave that bounces back and forth I
wait until the exact instant when that
wave reaches my other hand and then I
tug with that hand I'm able to add the
energy of these tugs together and create
a single strong wave of tension that is
bouncing back and forth through the
slinky the other fundamental that you
can build a ton of different tricks out
of is called the basic bounce I grip the
top if I pull down and I leave my hand
down here you'll see that it wants to
bounce back up then I need to give it
some help and I can get it to come back
to my hand I can make this harder by
bouncing off of the ground for instance
another way I can make the bounce more
difficult is by aiming for a Target
if you want you can even bounce your
Slinky off of another person the
weirdest thing I have bounced the slinky
off of was Howie Mandel's bald head
on America's Got Talent how I get it to
hit the bottle or any Target is the same
way a baseball player can throw a
baseball with accuracy you just practice
it a lot and your brain does the rest
why do kids love slinkies I mean it's
the same reason an adult with an open
mind loves Slinky psychedelic it's
colorful it moves in this weird funny
way that's completely novel and nothing
else moves like that to them it really
is a completely new thing and they're
just blown away by it
a Next Step you can do once you've got
the ground bounce is starting to do
flips
now this is a 180 degree flip so if you
look at this Slinky right here it's got
a blue top and a pink bottom and I'm
going to do a 180
and now it has a pink top and a blue
bottom another step you can take is to
do a 360 flip
once you can do that off the ground you
can start trying to do it from the
compressed position like this
these more advanced tricks that I'm
doing the techniques I'm not going to
reveal here because they're Trade
Secrets but they're all based off of
those fundamental movements I showed
earlier the Basic Energy beam and the
basic bounce
one of the tricks that took me the
longest to learn is the head bounce it's
there we go that took me maybe six
months of practicing just that trick for
20 to 30 minutes a day I've probably
spent about 1500 hours practicing with
the slinky in order to perform these
mind-blowing tricks Josh can't use any
old Slinky he has to consider the length
diameter and even the coil width of
every Slinky he uses these days slinkies
come in all different shapes and sizes
here I have an original metal Slinky now
this one has been damaged this is what
happens when you try to do tricks with a
metal Slinky because of the amount of
force that's required you will instantly
bend it here we have a square Slinky
this one's pretty cool because it can do
this
it's also pretty decent for manipulation
it's not my favorite though just because
of the weight this one is quite big and
heavy and also the square shape makes it
more difficult to catch so here we have
two slinkies of the same diameter but
different lengths so this one
I can do most of the same tricks that I
can do
with the regular size one that I
normally use now this one obviously a
little bit longer this is going to
really limit the number of moves that
are possible with it it has its own
charms it's pretty unique to have a
slinky this giant so here we have the
widest Slinky I have ever seen it's
practically impossible for me to grip
which makes it terrible for manipulation
I could grip it like this but this is
not ideal this is a hyper spray what
makes a hyper spring great is the
proportions namely the width of the
individual coils but also length and the
diameter to where most people can grip
it and it's capable of the widest
variety of tricks with ideal sinkies in
hand Josh was kind enough to volunteer
to try and teach me the basic bounce in
just 20 minutes
I want you to just watch me keep your
eyes on this hand and watch what this
hand does
it just stayed still it just stayed
still okay cool this is called our
platform hand now I want you to watch
this other hand
grab the top uh-huh pulled it down this
hand is our grip hand so this hand is
going to grip the top of the slinky
about two or three coils okay and it's
gonna stay glued to the slinky the whole
time we're gonna sort of unfold it like
a book and bring it down below
oh my God that was perfect so the next
part is we got to get this to come back
to our hand we're gonna do an upside
down U so it's gonna be like whoop okay
like this and then try to catch it
that was pretty good
oh almost
so close all right our 20 minutes is up
let's see how good Wendy got at the
basic bounce three two one sleep
nope it feels like it should be easy but
being able to predict the movement and
respond to it is maybe not something
that I am coordinated enough to do no
you are you just have to practice as you
can see slinking is not as easy as Josh
makes it seem I took it home and even
with practice could never really land it
but Josh doesn't want that to discourage
anyone looking to start to any young
people out there that want to get really
good at Slinky manipulation I love to
see it wear your Slinky on your wrist
practice everywhere you go because there
is wide open Uncharted Territory out
there we are only at the tip of the
iceberg and there is so much more yet to
be discovered especially by the Younger
Next Generation